but drugs are [ __ ] up in general man
like i just want to say rest in peace
to [ __ ] dmx that's a sad one rest in
[ __ ] paradise man there's
i wish i was able to tell him this story
i'm about to tell you because this is
[ __ ] real deal and it's like
he means so much to my family it's crazy
it sounds nuts my wife was in [ __ ]
labor for 18
[ __ ] hours and she had the doula
there i told you they're on some
spiritual [ __ ]
a [ __ ] peruvian flute
playing for 17 [ __ ] hours straight
the peruvian flute music 17 hours in the
like the
bro she starts freaking out i'm like
they're listening we have an hour left
or we're gonna have to do a c-section or
whatever and
should no [ __ ] chance so
turn the [ __ ] peruvian flute music
off and i put [ __ ] dmx on
stop drop that [ __ ]
jumped out of her i swear on everything
it's on camera
it's on film as soon as the peruvian flu
music stopped dmx came on he [ __ ]
heard the dog
and he came out he just jumped out
i just amazed it the crate the [ __ ]
the doctor was going nuts because
everyone was just [ __ ] sick of that
[ __ ] everywhere i wanted to jump in
tired right i wanted to jump out of the
window from the music and so it just
changed the vibe of the room
man he [ __ ] popped right out on
everything like me i
can't make that up
that would have been a good one but he
came out on the hit
stop drop shut him down open up shop
he had some [ __ ] jams